this is coal country
in the hunter valley a 13 000 strong
workforce dig and mine this land
australians building fortunes and
futures from the black gold they pull
from the earth
coal is so important to this area to
this community we believe that we've got
another 30 years left of this industry
to continue uh selling coal all around
the world so the last piece of coal
that's burnt in the world should be
hunna valley black coal if we turned off
coal now what would happen here we would
see social devastation
and in terms of jobs lost uh businesses
going bankrupt and people moving away
from this area
this community isn't just built on coal
it's intertwined in the very fabric of
society
people have given their lives to the
mines
the mines have given livelihoods to tens
of thousands of people
the cop 26 call to phase out coal power
has gone unanswered in australia a move
supported by many here what these guys
are attempting to do is put a dead man
switch in
on a certain date and say that's it now
what happens if you don't meet that
are we are we going to do rolling
blackouts so are you willing to roll the
dice and
risk
potentially the planet dying no i'm not
saying that we should do nothing there
are things that we can do to reduce the
carbon output but i don't think that
putting a switch in which is going to
act like a nuclear bomb on our economies
is a good idea
this is the side of the house that faces
all of the bides but this has gotten
worse
but even in coal country fears over
pollution and climate change have
started causing divisions
so what is that that you're wiping off
coldest it makes me angry it makes me
worried i mean that's in my lungs too
margo's family once made its money from
mining but for australia to have a
future she thinks coal has to be left in
the past
the government has boosted solar and
wind power pledged net zero emissions by
2050
but it's also signed off new mines
we're about to dig up more dirt
and and dig up more tons of coal for
many more years we just can't be doing
it anymore for the climate i think
the bill has sounded and it is time for
the
coal industries to start transiting out
of it
this isn't just a domestic battle
australia is the world's second biggest
exporter of coal
a global dealer of the planet's
filthiest fossil fuel
these communities have fought and died
for coal if australia bows to pressure
what happens to the people living here
if it doesn't what happens to the rest
of the world
is this a curtain call for coal
no i don't believe it is i mean have a
look in the backdrop of
uh cop you've got record high cold
demand all around the world so if there
was a last stand to be made on coal it
should be here in this country
the balance of energy economics and the
environment struck here will impact all
of our lives
australia is now facing its most
important power struggle siobhan robbins
sky news new south wales